oh the FBI has just announced a suspect
in the plot to kidnap Russell Crowe and
all I can say is Tom Hanks you should be
ashamed of yourself
our next presenters are the stars of the
sensational movie Crouching Tiger Hidden
Dragon
here they are Chalian fat and Michelle
Yeoh
create a cheering crowd in an ancient
Roman arena Megaman turned from skin to
bones or fresh in a storm swept ocean in
the world of visual effects anything is
possible
that's right even the laws of gravity
can be defied in this world the nominees
for best achievement and visual effects
are today the colosseum of Rome stands
in ruins but in the hands of nominees
John Nelson Neal kobold Tim Berg and Rob
Harvey the beauty and the majesty of
this ancient arena was restored to his
original glory in Gladiator in hollow
man Kevin Bacon plays a doctor who takes
his own medicine nominees Scottie
Anderson Craig hates Scott stop tank and
stand hogs
whose texture mapping and computer
animation to slowly turn the visible
until the invisible and it was a
perfectly nice day when the Andrea Gail
set out to see only to run into the
awesome special effects of nominees
Stefan Fangmeier hobby Jagger poor John
Frazier and Walt Conti who did indeed
create the perfect storm and I lost
close to
I knew it right your turn go and
announce it your turn
and the Oscar goes to gladiator
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for John Nelson near coal
coal gold timber and Rob Harvey
Wow Thank You members of the Academy for
this great honor first and foremost I'd
like to thank our director Ridley Scott
for his genius vision leadership and
Trust I'd like to thank all my great
team at mil film London we did the
visual effects Tim Burke Rob Harvey
Laura you know Nikki penny Emma Norton
Nancy st. John - Bill Schulz a ton of
other people I'm just forgetting right
now I'd like to thank our great
practical and prosthetic effects team of
Neil corbels with Neil corbelled Paulin
Ian Korbel Trevor Ward John Evans
Michelle Taylor and Dave hunter like to
thank everyone at DreamWorks and
Universal or class act a pleasure to
work with I'd like to thank my wife
Deborah my son miles my mom in heaven my
dad and family in Detroit happy birthday
dad I love you
the 73rd annual Academy Awards would be
right back with Rene Zellweger Goldie
Hawn and a very special musical event
you